[Musik]
hallo er verließ welt heute gibt's ein
basic video ich habe ja gesagt das
möchte alle taten alle grundrezepte mal
als basic video aufnehmen denn da kann
ich dann eure fragen beantworten heute
gibt es in meinem video einen biscuit
denn den bizkit habe ich noch nie so
wirklich als basic auffindung also wir
werden einen disput teig zubereiten bzw
mit biscuit masse ich muss mich doch
selber immer korrigieren
umgangssprachlich sagt man teig zu allem
aber im prinzip ist ein teig all das was
man kneten kann und eine masse all das
was eben gerührt wird daher bist wird
massa aber mehr beteiligt hefeteig
früher masse brand masse und so weiter
beim bist wird ist es so da bist wird
wird er wirklich ganz gerne für torten
verwendet er wird aber auch für bis mit
rollen zum beispiel benutzt und es ist
einfach ein super luftiger kuchen der
wirklich nur aus drei zutaten besteht
nämlich eier zucker und mehl und dann
kann man das ganze aber auch schön
abwandeln ich gebe aber eine prise salz
dazu mit kakao mit zitronen abrieb und
man kann wirklich diesen bis geht
innerhalb von wenigen minuten backen und
hat einfach den perfekten super luftigen
kuchen beim bis wird ist es so ihr habt
vier teile zwei teile mail und zwei
teile zucker das heißt auch wenn ihr mal
kein rezept parat habt könnt ihr euch
einfach diese formel merken oder ihr
könnt einfach sagen zwei teile ein
teilnehmer ein teil zucker also einfach
doppelt so viele eier als zucker und
dann habt ihr es wirklich schon und
könnt einfach jederzeit den bis wir zu
bereiten heute machen wir einen standort
bis wird also ganz hell einen
schokoladen biscuit und dann zeige ich
euch noch die alternative mit kokos
bluten zucker und die alternativen
mitwirken zucker die alternative mit
halbem zucker zeige ich euch jetzt nicht
denn imbiss gewinnt braucht ihr einfach
den zucker wegen des volumens damit
einfach die eier massa schon
aufgeschlagen werden kann und wenn ihr
dann einfach den zucker reduziert dann
fehlt einfach das volumen und beim bis
mir das auch so auch backpulver wird
verzichtet da einfach super lange
gerührt wird ich habe jetzt hier schon
mal die zutaten gerichtet ich will das
ganze wie gesagt vier mal machen und ihr
müsst wissen einer größe m hat ungefähr
50 gramm das heißt 11 4 eier habt habt
ihr 200 und dann rechnet er eben die
hälfte davon der zucker also 100 gramm
und auch 100 gramm mehl beim schoko bis
wird mache ich dann nur so dass ich etwa
30 gramm mehl durch cacau ersetzt und
das war es im prinzip schon eine prise
salz ist jedes mal noch dabei und ich
kann dann verfeinern mit strom karonga
oder mit tonkabohnen abrieb ich kann es
mit vanille extrakt verfeinert mit
zitronen oder orangen abrieb mit likör
oder egal mit was auch immer noch sind
die welt und jetzt ganz wichtig bevor
ihr anfang zu backen unseren zum einen
richtet ihr euch die zutaten und wiegt
sie vorher ab und zum anderen hat sie
jetzt direkt schon mal dem backofen vor
denn der fiskus später sofort ihren
backofen machen rühren also kaufen
vorhalten
wichtig beim bis wird ist jetzt dass die
eier zimmer warm sind und ich mache es
tatsächlich so wenn ich einkaufe dann
lag ich die auch bei zimmertemperatur es
steht ja auch immer drauf zu kühlen ab
zu verbrauchen bis und daher lade ich
die zimmertemperatur und eier sind wir
uns sowieso im dauergebrauch das heißt
die haben wir immer frisch da und die
wirklich schönen zimmer waren lassen
damit sie sich einfach voluminöser
aufschlagen in alten rezepten sieht man
noch ganz oft das da heißes wasser dazu
gegeben wird aber das braucht man
eigentlich gar nicht und wie gesagt auch
backpulver wird auch verzichtet da eben
alles über lange geführt wird das habe
ich hier die eier denn zucker und das
salz und es gibt beim biscuit entweder
das ein kessel oder zweikämpfe verfahren
das heißt zwei kessel würde bedeuten ich
schlag das eiweiß separat auf und die
eigelbe separat braucht man aber im
prinzip nicht ich habe es früher auch
gemacht habe es auch im buch so mit drin
in meinem alten im allerersten aber man
braucht wirklich nicht wenn man die eier
masse lange genug hört und mit langem
einig wirklich lange das heißt ihr dürft
jetzt wirklich etwa 15 bis 20 minuten
rühren bis die masse fast schon steif
geschlagen ist wie bei schnee so fest
jetzt nicht aber wirklich ganz lange
rühren das heißt auch wenn in hand
höhere habt sehr lange röhren ich gebe
jetzt hier bei dem standard bis wird
einfach bisschen tonka wanka dazu und
schaltet die maschine an ich werde
parallel gleich noch den schoko bis
goethe zu bereiten in der separaten
maschine und habe jetzt hier auch schon
meine torten ringe gerichtet ich mache
jetzt gleich 20 zentimeter aber aus der
menge könnt ihr auch einen 26 gebacken
je nachdem wie hoch ihr eben den bizkit
haben wollt oder ihr könnt daraus auch
eine festplatte backen die einfach schön
er voluminös und auch einfach schön
luftig ist und jetzt heißt einfach um
[Musik]
so sieht die masse echt
richtig richtig schön jetzt braucht ihr
keine küchenmaschine und auch kein
handrührgerät mehr denn der rest wird
einfach so hergestellt und zubereitet
ich nehme jetzt nämlich das mehl ich
mache zurzeit wird das nicht ich mache
erst mal den hellen teig das muss auf
jeden fall gesiebt werden und dann jetzt
keine klümpchen gibt
[Musik]
und jetzt am besten ganz vorsichtig mit
dem schneebesen wirklich von außen nach
innen unterheben
[Musik]
da ist superwichtig wirklich nicht so
hören sondern unter zu heben ganz ganz
vorsichtig und auch wirklich nur so
lange wie nötig ist das wirklich keine
mail partikel mehr zu sehen sind und
jetzt auch nicht an den schlüssel rand
klopfen denn ihr habt die luft wirklich
mühsam unterschlagung ein gerät und wenn
er jetzt an den rand der schüssel klopft
dann klopft ihr aber die luft wieder
raus das headquarter
jetzt wie gesagt einfach im bug in baku
und da packe ich einfach super gerne in
bringen weil zum einen der teig nicht
sehr lange backen muss also im hat
wirklich so 20 prozent zeitersparnis
das heißt wenn ihr allgemein meine
rezepte macht und dann springform zum
beispiel hat müsste recht eine längere
wartezeit mit einrechnen und zum andern
packt der drei gleichmäßiger und reist
oben nicht ein das heißt es entsteht gar
nicht erst diese kuppel in der mitte die
dann oben ein reich und schön
verstreichen
und wie gesagt habe ich jetzt noch den
zweiten schon gerührt dann kann ich
nämlich beide gleichzeitig backen das
wenn ich bei 20 zentimeter durchmesser
nicht immer ganz gut und ihr werdet
sehen den kommunen wird mega locker ganz
ohne begründung er macht jetzt die
schoko version
[Musik]
es ist der biss gehört das denn einfach
so sei im moment die kann man einfach
nicht in worte nicht mit worten
beschreiben das ist ein klasse das muss
man zu bereiten
streichen und dann ganz wichtig im
vorgeheizten backofen backen also nicht
jetzt hier den bizkit stehen lassen
sondern der muss sofort in den heißen
backofen ansonsten habe ich jetzt
gemacht ansonsten
verliert er nämlich die ganze luft die
hier eingeschlagen haben das ist glaube
ich auch so ein fehler den fehler dass
sie entstehen lassen mai nämlich wo er
den ofen vorheizen und dann verbocken
[Musik]
tier ist so den packe ich jetzt bei 180
grad ober unterhitze wenn ich eine
platte backe dann packe ich die bei 210
grad und hitze ganz heißen ganz schnell
damit sie einfach nicht trocknet aber
hier möchte ich ja nicht dass die
oberfläche verbrennt daher wirklich 180
jetzt komme ich zu den zwei alternativen
weil eben immer wieder gefragt wird kann
ich dem zucker ersetzen könnten
austauschen kann ich ihnen reduzieren
deswegen gibt es jetzt den biss wird
auch noch mit kokos blüten zucker und
wie gesagt mit birken zu kommen ich
persönlich muss dazu sagen
kuchen ist ja eine süßigkeit und ich
finde wenn man alles in maßen ist und
ich den massen dann ist es auch erlaubt
einfach zu sündigen und was süßes zu
essen vor allem wenn man sich ausgewogen
und gesund ernährt und wenn ich eine
süßspeise esse dann esse ich sie als
süßigkeit und weiß man auch dass zucker
enthalten ist deswegen bin ich
eigentlich so der große fan von zucker
reduzierung oder auch von
zuckeraustauschstoffen weil ich einfach
oft an das gefühl habe dass menschen
denken wenn jetzt kein zucker drin ist
oder eben kein weißer zucker sondern ein
austausch zucker oder weniger zucker
drin ist kann man mehr essen und ich
glaube das ist einfach so die falsche
botschaft und bei kokos briten sogar zum
beispiel das ist wird oft gesagt ist
eine tolle gesunde alternative zu weißem
zucker aber auch da muss man wissen
kobus blüten zucker hat fast genauso
viele kalorien wie weißer zucker es
ist einfach so dass kokos blüten zucker
zwar da wird zwar gesagt dass der zucker
blutzuckerspiegel nicht so schnell
ansteigt und eben auch nicht so schnell
fällt aber man muss wissen es sind
trotzdem kalorien es ist trotzdem zucker
und vor allem ist kokos blüten zucker
einfach eine importware also die wechsel
nicht bei uns sondern bekommt einfach
aus weiter weg und man muss man wissen
was belastet einfach auch die umwelt und
gesündere und regionale alternativen
gibt es vielleicht nicht sogar in sirup
oder
davon sieben niederlagen sind auch nicht
das ist nicht immer so man muss einfach
immer abwägen was man möchte und ich
glaube einfach dass man alle aspekte
beachten sollte und nicht sagen sollte
cocos bilden zucker ist als mega gesund
denn ich finde die umweltaspekte sind
halt doch auch schon richtig was
bewirken zucker für mich das problem ist
es ist halt auch kein natürliches
produkt und es hat zwar weniger kalorien
und dann wird auch noch gesagt es soll
gut zu den zähnen sein aber es soll
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich ich pflege meine
zähne nicht gerade in einem biscuit da
geht es wahrscheinlich gesündere
alternativen und deswegen wenn ihr sowas
macht es macht gerne und probiert auch
auf aber haltet immer im hinterkopf ist
eine torte oder ein stück kuchen und da
sollte man glaube ich mich auf
gesundheitsaspekte achten außer außer
und das muss ich sagen ausser man muss
es gesundheitlich machen wenn man
diabetiker zum beispiel ist dann finde
ich es wichtig dass man weiß wie man den
zucker austauschen kann und ersetzen
kann aber ich für mich als normal
gesunder mensch sage ich jetzt mal der
sich bewusst ernährt ich mag einfach mit
zucker und der kommt aus der region und
dann so nix importiert werden und
manchmal nämlich kokos blüten zucker
weil er einfach schön malt sich schmeckt
und karamell ich schmeckt aber beten
zucker nämlich eigentlich
ich es dann einfach ein apfel
okay ich zeigt sich trotzdem damit wird
es auch haben und ich hatte auch schon
mal im mandl rührteig gemacht und da
auch diese zucker alternativen zur
reduktion und so weiter könnt ihr euch
gerne anschauen und ich bin auch immer
an für euch aber die aspekte mal
anzusprechen fand ich schon nicht
[Musik]
haile wird
durch skills läuft uns winken also jetzt
bitte noch mal
ja jetzt ganz oldschool ein haus
und jetzt unternehmen also das ist hier
die masse mit bis hin zu kommen optisch
erkennt man 0 unterschied
was hier jetzt hier machen werde meinen
teil habe ich dann mit diesen traum wahr
gemacht eine mit vanille den mache ich
jetzt mit zitrone april nämlich auch
sehr lecker
ein wenig
[Musik]
ich habe übrigens die backzeit musste
ich noch mal nachstellen ich hatte 20
man natürlich viel zu wenig habe ich
wollte nicht übertreiben am anfang und
zwar dann doch insgesamt 30 es kommt
natürlich darauf an einmal auf backofen
dann kommt auf die backform an dann
kommt es darauf an wie groß der
durchmesser ist aber ist so bei dem 20
zentimeter formen waren zwar 180 grad
und hitze in der mittleren einschub
meiste wirklich 30 minuten und da ist
auch wichtig nicht so früh die
backofentür zu öffnen denn ansonsten
sagt er wieder ein du bist da gibt es
auch eine goldene faustregel die goldene
faustregel besagt nämlich öffnet die
backofentür erst nach mindestens zwei
drittel und der backzeit also wenn dem
rezept steht keine ahnung 30 minuten
dann öffnen sie wirklich erst frühestens
nach 20 minuten also lasst wirklich
erstmal zwei drittel backzeit vergehen
und dann erst öffnen damit der kuchen
eben nicht zusammenfällt und am besten
gar nicht öffnen sondern eher rockig mal
gucken meistens sieht man es dann auch
das hier ist jetzt die masse mit kokos
blüten zucker erkennt man direkt an der
farbe und am duft da gebe ich jetzt auch
kein mangel extrakt und das so dazu bei
dass
murat
komm herein
orad orad
orad
hat jetzt der sturm fairground
nicht
die welt retten samana bin laden morath
macht seinen stammtisch wieder in man
hier
also in den laden heißt in unserem shop
genau gespart jetzt aber ich glaube die
zuschauer warten würden
sie sind den ganzen weg angereiste
gestellt hatten ja ok
in mannheim und ich bin immer hier ich
hatte hier die stellung wie mail oder so
ich mache ein grundrezept biscuit okay
ich bin um 18 uhr
weil ich vor der kamera
[Musik]
option eins ist wie gesagt schon
gebacken und ich habe nach 25 minuten
langes stäbchen pro buch macht das heißt
mit einem zahnstocher einfach in die
höchste stelle mittig eingestochen und
da waren noch ein paar komische dran und
habe es dann noch mal eben fünf minuten
nach backen lassen jetzt habe ich ihn
raus geholt er steht jetzt hier seit
etwa fünf minuten und jetzt werde ich
aber den kuchen direkt raus lösen
damit er einfach nur schöne glatte
oberfläche bekommen ok
hat sich hier ganz vorsichtig jetzt
damit daran schön wird
mit einem back for messer am rand
entlang lösen
[Musik]
und ich lasse jetzt so einfach mal
komplett abkühlen ich denke so einfach
mit einem tuch ab damit sie nicht
austrocknet und das auch nichts drauf
fällt und dann zeige ich euch denken
effekten hoffentlich perfekten ist wird
gleich
[Musik]
also ich habe die bis mit bilden
herausgelöst nach dem backen und dann im
regen aber abkühlen lassen jetzt habe
ich den ring entfernt und die vac folie
darunter sind sie fertig und im prinzip
könnt ihr bis getötet einfach super gut
vorbereiten ihr könnt sie einfrieren und
ich finde es halt echt praktisch denn
mal perfekt 20 drei zutaten eier zucker
und mehl und macht in seinem kuchen
einfach nur 100 gramm zucker und das ist
echt nicht viel es schnell gebacken
dennoch liebe ich auch andere teile wie
man öl teig weil die einfach super
saftig sind aber daher ist einfach super
schnell gemacht und dann kann man so
eine sache creme reinhauen und da hat
man eine geniale torte einem schneide
ich jetzt auf erwartet mal welcher weiß
welcher das ist der show kochen das ist
der normale
dann ist das der mit kokos blüten zucker
und das mitwirken zucker so und dann kam
hat die nämlich nach dem backen und
abkühlen schönen durchschneiden am
besten sogar einen tag wagen stehen
lassen aber abgedeckt damit sie sich
besser durch schneiden lassen dann
krümmels nicht so
und dann guckt mal da habt ihr den
perfekten des plans und
der ist mit tom kawara das richtig
huawei ist sehr luftig und locker ja das
war's eigentlich
viele nehmen übrigens auch stärker mit
in den biskuit das muss man aber gar
nicht der wird zwar dadurch dann ein
bisschen feinfühliger aber auch
schneller trockener und jetzt möchte ich
euch noch ganz gerne ich will euch noch
verraten weil ich das ganze basiswissen
habe diese hohe kunst der konditorei es
gibt nämlich einen menschen in meinem
leben
von dem ich alles gelernt habe und
wo ich mir einfach alles von abschaum
und ich schaue zu
und kredite kommen bittet bitte zeigt
ich will einfach dass jeder weiß dass
ich das backen von dir genannten
zeiten
kann es ein paar
versteckte von 111 300 jahre lang ist
ein praktisch
einfach versteckt und ich wollte einfach
dass ihr fest in diesem basic bis tritt
rezept video das r der mann ist der alle
rezepte zu ihren treffen
danke
hallo herr zu kommen besser ins bild
[Musik]
es schmeckt
so wie hier
ja
da habe ich auch mal hören ja
eine torte backen
diane tabak du weißt ich habe die tore
zwei gebracht um nur ja sagen in japan
war aufgegangen und wir packen jetzt
eine torte also das war das basis video
das grundrezept
und die 112 methode bzw die 224 methode
habe ich von ihm
und daraus könnte jetzt alle torten
kreieren aber dafür könnt ihr einfach
beim training vorbeischauen denn er hat
alles auf seinem kanal und auch deinen
backbuch
also falls ihr weitere basic videos
sehen und schreibt einfach gerne und ich
arbeite gerne auch alle anderen tage für
euch ab vielleicht könnte ja schreiben
welche nicht als nächstes machen sollen
das rezept gibt es bei freddy aber auch
auf salehs innsbruck de oder in meiner
macht ja nur hochzeitstorten noch gern
fragen selbst dafür zu plädieren
zwei stunden vorlauf damals mit figur
ja figur nennt man figur würde sagen es
ist wachs ich habe die nächste idee für
dürfte wachsen oft hatte
und eine harry potter tag lang wird und
wer harry potter torte muss zurück
[Musik]